I did The Descendants movie and all  those kids are like my kids just like  the glee kids are just like the  hairspray kids are but Cameron Boyce was  one of my babies and I want to say that  that what you saw in the video is really  him that was that was really how who he  was that's really yeah I remember that  we were you know five six seven eight  rehearse and rehearse on her side and  that kid never ran out of energy and I  said you're like Justin Timberlake  you're like a you're like a hummingbird  you never stop this is a true story  you're like you never stop you know how  they just never stop well I'm in Vegas  you know Sin City I'm Leyna I'm looking  at the day in the morning that I found  out I'm laying there and what do you  think flew by me oh I know I I thought  okay cam I got you  [Music]